zurück nach Deutschland 2023 soll es
kommen und Hartz IV ablösen es geht ums
Bürgergeld aber schon jetzt hagelt es
heftig Kritik zu lasch zu teuer zu
ungerecht auch der Prüfung des
Bundesrechnungshofs hält es offenbar
nicht stand das geht nun aus einem
veröffentlichten Bericht hervor die
Kritik unter anderem zu hoher Mehrkosten
für den Steuerzahler zu hohe Freigrenzen
ja und auch Arbeitsminister Hubertus
Heil der bekommt seinen Fett weg sein
Vorhaben weniger Strafen für
jobverweigerer zu verhängen werde kont
werde sich kontraproduktiv auswirken so
sagen die Experten und gerade für die
Opposition dürfte die Einschätzung des
Bundesrechnungshof eine Bestätigung sein
diese hatte das Vorhaben in den letzten
Wochen heftig kritisiert ja und ein
Kritiker des Bürgergeldes ist uns jetzt
zugeschaltet Carsten Linnemann
stellvertretendervorsitzender der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion Herr
Linnemann was genau stört sie denn am
Bürgergeld am geplant hallo Frau Müller
ja das Problem ist dass
wenn Sie ein System haben in Deutschland
wir sind ein Sozialstaat dann haben sie
ganz viele Menschen die diesen
Sozialstaat finanzieren das machen ja
nicht wieder Politiker oder das Geld
fällt ja auch nicht vom Himmel sondern
sind Menschen die in Deutschland
arbeiten gehen die
Sozialversicherungsbeiträge zahlen und
Steuern zahlen die finanzieren den
Sozialstaaten und damit ist eine
Akzeptanz auch gibt für diesen
Sozialstaat haben diese Menschen
natürlich ein Recht darauf dass man
vernünftig mit dem Geld umgeht das heißt
dass derjenige der das Geld bekommt auch
eine gewisse Bringschuld mitbringen muss
Gerd Schröder hat das mal genannt
Fördern und Fordern und dieses fordern
wird jetzt abgestellt weil de facto
Sanktionen in den ersten Monaten nicht
mehr verhängt werden wenn man sich nicht
an die Spielregeln hält es ist quasi ein
Fußballspiel ohne gelbe und rote Karten
ohne gelb und rote Karten funktioniert
kein Fußballspiel und ohne Sanktion
funktioniert kein Sozialstaat und
deswegen kritisieren sie das ja wir
gehen jetzt an die Grundfesten der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft dran und wir
hängen quasi die Agenda 2010 an den
Haken gerade Vermögen wird auch nicht
berücksichtigt hört sich so ein bisschen
an nach dem Prinzip gießkann und das
können wir uns in den Tagen ja alles
andere als leisten
genau ich habe also mich lässt das
Gefühl nicht los das ist im Kern um das
bedingungslose Grundeinkommen geht was
man perspektivisch gerne haben will
und dieses von dem halte ich gar nichts
ich verstehe auch gar nicht warum alle
Menschen das bekommen sollen und hier
gibt es einfach ein ganz
unterschiedliches Gesellschaftsbild wir
sind der Meinung dass derjenige der
arbeiten geht mehr haben muss als
derjenige der staatliche Leistung
bezieht
in Zukunft wird es aber viele Fälle
geben wo das nicht mehr der Fall ist und
ich mache ja den Menschen gar keinen
Vorwurf die das die das mitnehmen aber
wir als Staat haben die verdammte
Aufgabe die Anreize so zu setzen dass
wir nicht in Deutschland eine Schieflage
kommen und wir kommen in eine Schieflage
wenn diejenigen die arbeiten gehen das
Gefühl haben dass der Staat Geld
verprasst und nicht vernünftig mit
diesem Geld umgeht und das passiert bei
dieser großen reformt meine feste
Überzeugung und auch wenn man mir nicht
glaubt und denkt das ist ja ein
CDU-Politiker der muss das anders sehen
nein ich bin Fan der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft und die soziale
Marktwirtschaft funktioniert nur wenn
diejenigen die Geld vom Staat bekommen
auch eine gewisse Bringschuld mitgeben
und diese Bringschuld wird ausgestellt
aber gut kritik ist immer das eine wie
würden sie es denn besser machen einfach
so weitermachen wie vorher geht ja nun
auch nicht
warum nicht weil es doch auch an dem
jetzigen Prinzip große Kritik gibt vor
allem auch von den Leistungsträgern
ja das stimmt jetzt muss man natürlich
konkret werden eine Kritik zum Beispiel
teile ich das sind die sogenannten
hinzuverdienstregeln
derjenige der arbeiten geht
muss auch signifikant davon etwas
behalten dürfen wenn er gleichzeitig im
SGB II ist heute ist es so bis 100 Euro
darf ich das Geld eins zu eins behalten
danach wird es zu 80% angerechnet das
heißt es gibt 10.000 von Menschen in
Deutschland die nur für 100 Euro in
Anführungsstrichen arbeiten weil sie
sagen danach lohnt es sich ja und dieses
umzuändern dass ich Arbeit ja mehr
belohne als heute das wäre für mich eine
Reform das will ja auch die FDP da
unterstützen wir auch die FDP
ausdrücklich aber bei den anderen Sachen
nicht und deswegen wundert es mich auch
dass die FDP bei diesen Bürgergeld
mitmachen sagt Carsten Linnemann
Dankeschön für das Gespräch
[Musik]